hey guys i am Jessa McDonald you are
tuned into games but news and it's the
31st of March also known as the last day
you can ever trust anybody ever
seriously be careful tomorrow first up
of things that everybody's a fan of new
generation consoles and now that
includes which a3 dev CD Projekt RED the
dev have said that developing for the
xbox one ps4 and PC have allowed them to
go nuts in terms of visuals global head
of marketing Tamar's Jezebel ski
apologies for the pronunciation
butchering said I think we're in a good
moment we don't have to choose between
better graphics or performance on either
pc all consoles right now we can just
create the best game possible next up
there is a new king in Xbox town and
it's predictably none other than Phil
Spencer the dirt who's been pushing the
pro Xbox line hard as of late has been
officially promoted to head of Xbox
he'll be taking the lead on xbox Xbox
Live and the creative teams at Xbox
music video and Microsoft Studios
looking forward Spencer has said our
mission is to build a world-class team
work hard to meet the high expectations
of a passionate fanbase create the best
games and entertainment and drive
technical innovation yeah it seems the
niche may be the new mass-market at
least that's according to square enix
after their success with bravely default
the 3d s exclusive sold like hotcakes
and now squares president Yosuke Matsuda
has said that the company lost its focus
trying to make games with global appeal
Matsuda has said if you focus too much
on the global aspect you might lose
sight of who you're actually making the
game for if you find yourself with an
xbox live gold subscription here are the
games you can get your hands on for free
in April the mildly underwhelming
selection of xbox live games has been
and continues to be an issue for you
guys but let me know if this month
changes your mind Microsoft is set to
give you hitman absolution and dead
light it's not a meaty selection albeit
not a bad one but is it good enough for
your 60 bucks a year for reference
PlayStation Plus is offering up
mercenary Kings Batman Arkham City
stealth Inc a clone in the dark castle
of illusion starring mickey mouse
velocity ultra
and pixel junk monsters ultimate HD let
me know which of these selections you
would prefer regardless of which console
you happen to have in your house either
in that comment section down below or
you can say hiding me on my twitter
where I'm at jeff smith done that is all
the newsie stuff that I've got for you
today but let me know all your favorite
april fools jokes as they unravel we'll
let you know our favorites and love it
whoever got tricked tomorrow